welcome to the Creator Launchpad we want
to see your idea for a new original show
concept so get together with your
friends and shoot an episode we'll watch
your video and if we love it we'll hire
you to join our team and direct more
episodes click on the link in the
description below for more information
I don't even I don't even know what
queer means because you have a different
definition I'm sure you have one I'm
sure you have one and I'm sure you have
one 2022 baby you better look up what
queer means it's often juice awesome
thank you
step forward if you agree with the
prompt
it is important that parents honor their
children's boundaries
I like the phrase boundaries breed
intimacy
if you don't have that respect mutual
respect for one another how can I be
open with you as a child there's that
lack of trust if you're not respecting
boundaries
it's also important because each kid is
different and I have a brother and
boundaries that work for me don't work
for him and so my parents parent both of
us according to what we need and that
involves having different boundaries so
and like to honor your child's
boundaries does not mean at your
boundaries there's a deficit at my
boundaries like my kid is not going to
be cussing me out tell me what he's not
going to do is none of that I can I can
respect my child and have a 14 year old
son and he respects me I've never had
any issues with Rebellion or I guess
disrespect in that way because we
communicate about everything now and you
know there is a line of course that you
don't want to cross you know especially
when it comes to the safety of the child
it is 100 safety and it just means you
respect their emotions as a human it
doesn't mean you let your kid do
whatever you want I think that's a
common misconception
can the disagree or step forward
like it if the prompt was worded almost
a little bit differently because it puts
importance on my kids boundaries where I
think as a parent we set those
boundaries but I like what you said
where you said that just because uh
boundaries are set doesn't give you know
your child the ability or the reason to
cuss you out because it's like oh well
I've set these boundaries up and that's
my boundary it seems like people are
equating boundaries with emotions and I
would not do that I would say that their
emotions are different from their the
boundaries that we as parents should be
setting for them because I don't know
about you but when I was a child I broke
every boundary that my parents set for
me and they were there for specific
reasons to keep me safe so if we just
allow our children to have no boundaries
or we allow them to set the standard for
the boundaries I think that they're just
not emotionally to bring that word back
capable of doing that and keeping
themselves safe I think that's our job
as parents yeah I think to talk uh going
off of that that the the relationship
you have with a parent is very
contingent on the child uh knowing that
the parent has your best interest at
heart and like you said there were many
times in my childhood that I wanted to
do something and I didn't have the same
boundary that my parents did maybe I
didn't have all the information I'm glad
that they protected me and they had my
best interest at heart and I think that
that's important for the parent-child
relationship can I throw in a follow-up
question let's redirect and think about
boundaries too as autonomy okay
encompassing what though as an example a
little kid doesn't feel comfortable
hugging a family member you must hug
them anyway that's your uncle hug them
and they're trying to tell you
absolutely not I was actually about to
talk on that I think it's less about the
child setting the boundary with the
parent I think parents should definitely
like have the final say in terms of
those boundaries but I think it's more
about fostering conversation with the
children that you are an individual you
do have autonomy just for this days of
your life I will take the lead I am the
parent but instilling in the child that
you are your own person and you're not
just an extension of me I have a
six-year-old a two-year-old and 11th
month old son so there is no boundaries
because you can't have boundaries if
there's no foundation in order you know
so uh for me what I strive to do is to
uh with my six-year-old is just give her
lots of words of affirmation and be the
lead in everything we do you know she
rides horses we go out to the range she
shoots guns a lot of the structure and
Foundation that we're planning is you
know in the Outdoor World it's not based
off social media tablets cell phones and
reality TV shows but if I'm just saying
well you know I'm gonna wait until she
tells me what her boundaries are I'm
gonna wait and see how she feels well
that's not a parent that's a friend but
isn't that what happens the parent it's
at the the precedent this is the law
this is the rules and regulations the
foundation whether it's Christianity
whether it's whatever that you believe
in your household and then you get you
do have your autonomy as a child and you
do start challenging your parent because
your ideas and their ideas might not
align just the same way anymore and that
is when the kid has it so if your
daughter let's say said you know what
Daddy I don't want to wear these clothes
no more I don't want to wear this pink
dress I don't want to wear these Frills
I don't want to dress like a girl I want
to cut my hair off what would you say
that wouldn't be up to me that would be
up to her mother okay what would you
what would you guys say I would imagine
together
um
well you know in all honesty I um I do
work I have a career and stuff but I'm a
stay-at-home father at the same time so
I'm the one who dresses I'm the one who
does the hair but at the same time it
would be up to her mom to decide okay
well how can we go about this and also
if she's having these feelings we're
gonna stop for a second that just hop on
and say okay well she says that she
wants to dress like a boy now or she
says she wants to do this this now well
let's see where it's coming from because
obviously if she's not seen it in our
home then she saw it from somewhere
that's not true I was five years old
when I told my mom I do not want to wear
this pink dress and my parents are
pastors or Christian I was adopted in
Michigan Grand Rapids Michigan I'm just
I'm just saying all these things I was
the only black child in my entire School
District we were in the paper for being
the old for bringing multiculturalism to
the school district so I didn't see any
tomboys I didn't see no gay folk I
didn't see nothing what my point is I
had a call
I guess you say a calling of autonomy
for who I am and I'm Unapologetic for
because I always follow that as a six
seven eight nine-year-old and thankfully
I had two parents that might not have
understood right but did fortify me to
be myself and never forced me to wear
the clothes that I didn't want to wear
my thing is absolutely give a strong
foundation for your children that's your
right you wouldn't have brought children
in this world to not do that but you got
to be a listener if your child is saying
something that Connor's like wait where
is this coming from oh absolutely it
might not be coming from social media or
TV it might be coming from their heart
and their authentication absolutely but
that's also our job as parents to search
their heart you know just because a
child says absolutely to search your
child's heart absolutely or accept your
child who they are search a child's
heart I don't think we're actually in a
conversation they'll even be talking
about dressing or or how your kid feels
about their gender identity six years
old you can't your child we're talking
about boundaries we're not talking about
we're talking about orientation with
children talking about
think I was a pirate but my parents
didn't cut off my arm and attach a hook
like not everything
no but it's not though but what I'm
saying is you don't accept everything
simply because they say it like
self-mutilation and accepting your
daughter for being gay is a little bit
my friend my point is that you don't
just blindly accept for anything you do
accept them for some things but it's not
just blind they said it and therefore we
should accept them for what they said
it's not necessarily accepting it's more
of letting them explore it's more of
them giving them an option to find
themselves
a reckless I have twins and uh twin
girls and they're five now and a two and
a half one of them
didn't want to wear dresses anymore she
was like adamant about it at two and a
half and I'm like
whoa this is powerful and we went with
it we wanted her to explore that we
wanted to make sure that she felt
comfortable in her own skin on what she
was wearing and I didn't want to put
that on her and make sure that you know
she has this femininity that maybe she
doesn't feel like she has you know
that's not saying that she's gay or
she's lesbian or anything she just
doesn't like dresses I would agree and
to this day she's five and she still
doesn't wear dresses and she might she's
like dresses in a couple of years she
might change her mind and I actually
like dresses yeah and that's her choice
I have a question it's personal to you
because I don't know if I heard it
correctly did you say you were adopted I
was okay you had adopted parents do you
think they're the only parents I
recognize is my favorite but I was
adopted do you think that their
willingness to be let's just use the
word liberal in acceptance and want and
you wanting to do the things that you do
is because they're your adoptive parents
and maybe that they felt this obligation
that they want to be closer to
absolutely not I'm the only one adopted
in my family and my mom and dad actually
do not believe in my lifestyle and
they're Unapologetic for that and I
respect it because everybody has to
believe in what they believe in so even
though they don't believe that my
lifestyle is necessarily of God or of
their faith we can still come to the
terms and love each other and be with
each other because I'm not my thoughts
and my parents aren't their thoughts
either we're bigger than that and they
have the right to believe it right now
move on to the next prompt
it's best for a child to have a mother
and a father
going right here
right here I'm gonna set this one down
I thought about that one for a second I
did yeah
well I mean I think it's kind of obvious
right for for a plethora of reasons but
I think the the ordered way is you know
a mother and a father for for two
different people that have two different
and distinct purposes uh we all know
mothers are just inherently better at
nurturing they they provide life they
give life and I think both of those two
distinct roles are absolutely important
and integral to uh Child Development I
think yeah I can speak to my own
experience I had uh two parents in the
home a very loving and it was really
vital to have a masculine figure and
also a feminine figure I think if you
have too much of either that can affect
you in negative ways as a kid the
problem that I have with the same sex
parenting is that when you have a
same-sex couple that has a child they're
necessarily depriving that child of a
mother and the father and they're
excluding a parent in one of those
important roles from the child and we we
have a lot of data on this social
scientists have tons of studies and
research about this of decades that
non-biological parents are more
transitory than biological parents that
when a child loses a parent that there's
a lot of trauma involved and so I think
it's important to realize that Sexes are
different and children need models for
both of those things and it isn't to say
that homosexuals can't love and commit
and it's also not to say that
heterosexuals can't be bad parents I
think we know that as well but it is to
say that we shouldn't set up a system in
which children are intentionally put in
homes that are fatherless or motherless
that isn't fair to the child I feel like
same-sex parents adopting are thrusting
the child into their lifestyle instead
of realizing and asking the better
question which is what is best for that
child can I hear the side that we will
be good parents but no man can be a
mother and no woman can be a father and
even if you are the best same-sex couple
in the world you still are necessarily
denying that child a parent and I
believe that children have rights and
that the most important right is a right
to a mother and a father and they have
that right by virtue of being brought
into this world by those two people
I also don't add on to that because like
you touching on like the masculinity the
femininity the thing is you can only
display so much masculinity and
femininity the thing is like it's a
matter of your biological woman and
you're trying to exert as much
masculinity as possible at the end of
the day a child is going to grow up in a
same-sex household and they're gonna go
to school and then see that other
parents have a father figure a mother
figure and they're gonna grow up and
start and just all this stuff about
same-sex couples like gender all this
stuff is going to come to them at a very
young age they're one-dimensional
they're not going to take it in the same
way that we do so I just feel like at
from a very young age it would confuse
the kid I was raised by a single mother
and so I was raised by all women
um so like I was saying before you know
I do hair I grew up in salons I grew up
you know watching my mom getting her
eyebrows waxed and I was always
um you know masculine as a young boy but
the validation and the insecurities just
continue to grow as it became older as
far as working and being committed to
something and finishing a task those
were areas that I lacked in but one area
that I knew about and was so familiar
about was women but as far as having a
man say hey this is actually what the
woman is for she's not to be your play
thing she's actually a valued person
with emotions and standards and morals
and values and this is how you should
you know treat a woman so to have a
father in my life would have kept me
from doing a ton of stuff that ended up
hurting me emotionally later on and
causing a lot of trauma you know so now
that I have a son I hug him and give him
that masculine if you would say
um you know emotional embrace you know
and I think that's important you can't
just get that from one or the other or
the same sex I believe I believe it can
only come from a mother and a father
absolutely yeah well I also
not only is it you know as a Christian
it's not biblical to represent that to
our children but I don't think it's a
sustainable model either either if
you're looking at it from that
perspective like if we're going to
normalize same-sex households we will
have a very difficult reproduction issue
down down the line think of every single
family suddenly became a single sex
household there's a reason why mammals
have a male and a female and they
reproduce you know that's just that's
the way we're built that's the way we're
built biologically and from God
I don't agree with most of the you guys
said
um but I do agree about balance okay I
am a queer mother of a 14 year old male
and I believe that he definitely
benefits from a male in his life as well
as me in his life now the thing that you
guys really aren't touching on is that
most queer families are not just the
deficit of the opposite sex
there's a lot of extended family like I
make sure that my son has lots of male
influence because I know like you like
what you're talking about is a thousand
percent true especially in the black
communities the destruction of the black
household is just a whole different
conversation but because I know that it
is my it is my responsibility to make
sure she's got a strong male influence
or a few of them in his life now if
they're not a father they can be a
father figure I'm adopted so I don't
necessarily agree with everything you
said about the biology of family because
I believe the only thing that's real in
this world is love and I do believe
anybody can love and fortify a child a
beautiful environment but I do believe a
child does benefit from male and female
energy and that is best of mine
so I disagree
um clearly uh uh being a two male
household uh with two uh little girls
like you were saying you know I have a
lot of strong women in my life and in my
husband's life and you know we we make
sure that they are part of our Lives
they are part of our girls lives that
they know them very well that they feel
comfortable with them and I have even
told them at five years old you know if
you don't feel comfortable ever coming
to me about any kind of situation you
have your aunt you have your grandma you
have these awesome amazing women in your
life that you can talk to and you should
feel open about it do you really think
that it's your extended family's job as
like you mentioned like strong female
figures do you think it's their job for
them to parent your own kid because
they're not parenting no it's just an
influence we were talking about like
extended relatives but what about
immigrant families where all of your
Senate relatives are in a different
country a different time zone it doesn't
it doesn't have to be family though it
can be like my family it can be chosen
family it's just some woman or some man
in your life that has a relationship
with that child and it's not their job
to parent but it's their job to maybe
step in and give that like I know for me
I have two dads and I have strong female
figures in my life they never parented
me but sure I know that they're there if
I need them I mean you know when I got
my period I went to my dad's I didn't
want to go to any woman because they're
my parents and they made me feel loved
and there was I had never ever once
wanted a mom sought a mom thought I was
missing something because I didn't have
a mom and I'm sick and tired of people
telling me that I am missing something
because I'm just not it's because you
didn't have it
um yeah but do you feel like you're
missing something or you're not missing
having two dads because you didn't have
it well no no that's not what we're
talking about because what happened no
no because what happens is you're
missing out then well because I don't
have two dads
no no hold on hold on we all know you
know this and I know this there's
there's this bond that a mother and
child had that nobody can replace I
don't care if it's another dad I don't
care if it's and I don't care if it's a
grandmother wrong there was a study done
showing that the fathers formed the same
biological connections studies mean
nothing I want to hear him
right here what's he saying you saying
that I've never cared about having a mom
it never bothered me I have two dads
they're great you're saying that because
you don't have your mother which kills
me that kills me to think that you never
knew
doesn't kill me that is wild what if her
what if her mom what if her biological
mom let's just say her biological
problem was a drug addict a prostitute
like my biological mom that did not hold
me the first three months
but this is a real life scenario this is
a real life scenario I don't I don't I
don't miss that company but you don't
know that because it because you don't
know you don't know that because you're
not me exactly but what I'm whatever
other
queering first of all first of all I
don't I don't even I don't even know
what queer means because you have a
different definition I'm sure you have a
different different definition I'm sure
you have one I'm sure you have one and
I'm sure you have 2022 baby you better
look up what queer means it's often used
so you guys so hold on you guys have the
exact same definition of what a queer
person I think that finished from school
from schooling from from Academia okay I
know I don't think any part of the
conversation really bothered me so much
I think the the one thing that I wish I
could have nailed down was a clear
definition of of what being queer is I
understand that each person and I
actually said it each person probably
has his or her own definition you know
the same way if they asked us what a
conservative was we probably would have
had a definition for it but I just wish
that you know that definition would have
helped me frame maybe some of my
questions a little bit better that I had
yeah I'm talking about you guys right
here but you guys we're all the same
here honey no we're all we're all human
beings
we are not all the same he's black I'm
I'm mixed white white We're not gonna
say oh my God whatever you characterize
me is a very small bit of me because you
don't know me I can't just exactly so I
wouldn't assume to say that
equality is what actually makes
everything good I mean we were just
talking about how you know they're that
somebody in your life like an ant is
filling the role of the mother I didn't
say filling the role but you said you
said some woman a mother is not some
woman a mother is a mother and no matter
who you are some woman who I can go to
if I need them and they're and she's not
missing out on a mother because she
doesn't have one and nobody should be
able to tell her that of course she has
a mother she just doesn't have a
relationship I didn't have my father my
whole entire you know childhood from the
age of 22 until now I have a good
relationship with my father I was
missing something
I didn't really have a great
relationship with my my mother never
talked to me never said two words to me
I had absolutely nobody so to say that
oh I don't need him we're being raised
by a single parent
a full foundationally economic
economics
at the end of the day I don't want my
household to be a free-for-all for
anybody and everybody to come with their
political views their religious views if
I say I don't want my daughter to have
sex before marriage I don't want my
best friend Susie to come inside
absolutely well you know you know well
you know that's what my house is I'm not
talking about you I'm talking about my
house I'm not talking about you I don't
know about your situation what I'm
saying is as far as me and my house I'm
not gonna let any everybody whether I
love them I understand what you guys are
saying about love I understand what you
guys are saying about love and I agree
to be heterosexuals but also children
need order absolutely so therefore so
therefore in a same-sex house the order
of the natural order is being Stripped
Away I'm not saying you don't love your
daughters I'm not saying that I'm saying
the order you love your your Two Dads
that's great they support you they love
you they do things for you they provide
for you that's amazing but you're
missing the substance of order that can
help you help guide you in different
directions can I speak please what am I
missing Point pinpoint exactly what I am
missing and how right what am I missing
from that fundamental difference between
a mother and a father okay so what can
you point to in me I don't know I don't
know you that's why I asked the question
originally I couldn't say this we don't
know you personally so when we say that
you're missing something from not having
a mother you're missing guidance in
different ways anybody can look anybody
can fabricate emotion
I have two daughters I can go to my
daughter and I can play Barbies with my
daughter she puts on her dresses I'll be
the king she's the princess and I can do
I can get on the ground Carl I can make
myself be feminine enough for me and her
to have a good time but the real
femininity can only come from her mother
I can only do so much
[Music]
we need to move on in just a moment we
haven't heard from Brittany or Alexa
I think it's really important to realize
that it takes a village it takes a
village to raise children
so with Elizabeth coming from a
two-parent household which was a big
topic for the agreeers here a two-parent
household I don't think she's missing on
anything I raise my children with my
wife
my daughter knows no different you know
she is not missing anything neither is
my son do you think one day they will
absolutely not I have a question I have
a question I don't know how to ask this
question was it like uh with you were
you with a male when you had your
daughter yes I was okay so I guess my
question is more so for people who are
for queer people who adopt children okay
okay
is there a agenda connected to it
to purposely for the sake of society
Community you know to adopt children
into your home to prove a point I think
that's I guess because I think that's
what causes the problem if you're having
a kid for a political agenda
kids all the all the time you always see
white families adopt black children from
Africa and I'm like why can't you adopt
you know a little white kid when you
look at television when you look at
reality TV I feel just from what I'm
seeing I don't go off of statistics and
data that's a bunch of BS I go off of
what I see when homeboy has said that he
doesn't believe in data or statistics I
don't think it was a subtle eye roll I
definitely got whiplash how else do you
make a point that is professional and
mature if you're not citing data and
you're not citing research and you're
calling it all that scrapped all of his
credibility for me you're talking about
kids of gay parents and you're saying
that they're all these things and I the
person you're talking about I'm sitting
here telling you you're wrong and you're
still interrupting me and you're still
invalidating me and you're still telling
me that your opinion must be right even
though you're not in my shoes that was
really shocking yeah I wanted to respond
to some earlier points we've been
talking a lot about what is natural with
this order
um I'd like to say that there are many
many studies of over 1500
non-human species of animals that have
they parent in their species children
that are not biologically theirs I also
don't think that reproduction is the
end-all be all of what a family is to be
you're allowed to have your own biblical
beliefs I totally understand that and
respect that what you're talking about
with sustainability I'm not suddenly
going to tell all the straight people to
suddenly partner up with people of the
same sex and no longer reproduce it's a
minority of people that are queer that
do want to have children and I just
think that they should all be allowed to
have children and I don't think that
they are depriving the children of
anything because I think the foundation
of what a family should be is to provide
a child with love and support and raise
them into respectable upstanding
citizens I think it's important to have
masculine energy to have feminine energy
to have any other energy that there is I
just don't think that that is
necessarily the job of the parents to
incorporate these gender
I think we all do
it's necessary for parents to have open
dialogue about sex with their children
I do believe it's necessary but I
believe you have to
do it at an appropriate age but once
they're ready then I think you should
have those conversations so that they
don't have to go outside the family for
that information I never felt
comfortable going to my parents
um at all or my mom I never felt
comfortable going to her I would like to
create a space for my child which I have
where I hope that no matter what happens
in her life that she feels comfortable
going to me at least and then I will
help her or together will determine if
she's actually ready for the
conversation and hopefully she is I
definitely agree with you I think
um it's so important to be able to have
a dialogue so that kids feel like they
can come to you and not necessarily
enforcing that you have to come to me
for this one thing is like when it's
much younger
I'm just I'm really sorry
I just haven't been told I was already
strong enough time
it's just a lot of trauma associated
with this
um
and it's not drama for my family it's
Trauma from people telling me it's wrong
I know my family is right and I know my
family is normal
I didn't know it I didn't know my family
was not normal until other people
decided to tell me that
and that was nobody else's business to
say that no one else that's business
absolutely and this is my biggest fear
for my two daughters for me I feel like
I have to prepare them as much as
humanly possible for that outside world
that can tell you that you're wrong or
that your family is wrong because that's
one of my biggest fears I wouldn't I
don't think anybody said wrong but
I grew up in a lesson ideal family a
less than ideal I think is where there's
nothing less ideal about her situation
this is what she's hearing though this
is what she is perceiving that she's
hearing it too I'm hearing invalidation
of her family at the structure she got a
two-parent household right now most
heterosexual families end up in divorce
we don't also every single rude a person
I know has a mom and a dad we don't
understand
how's the mom and a dad nobody royally
screwed up with two moms and Two Dads
that's that and honestly most gay kids
parents are straight we come from we
come from y'all well they all have to
biologically not necessarily no not the
address you're having they all came from
a straight relationship but our parents
are heterosexual no I'm I'm biologically
related to one of my dad's my brother's
biologically related to the other and
they had us via a donation surrogacy so
there's still a biological Connection in
my house but and and I'm glad I have
that connection but I also have one of
my dads who has straight parents was
adopted and it like you know it just
biology doesn't necessarily mean
anything and I I wish people would like
stress it less because that's where a
lot of the hate comes from is oh if
you're gay clearly something's wrong if
you have two dads clearly something is
wrong with you and like we automatically
assume that people children like me or
people like my parents aren't as good as
purely because they're different nobody
nobody said that no one said it in this
room but like the world says it and
that's not fair and let's just everyone
just take a breath just take a moment
before we Circle back to the prompt okay
just take a deep breath do we feel okay
to yeah
okay
it's necessary for parents to have open
dialogue about sex with their children
I would also say that from a young age
we can talk about things that are
involved with like sex ed but not
explicitly sex for instance like consent
is a very important topic that I think
should be brought up as young as
possible we mentioned before about the
case of you don't have to hug your uncle
if you don't want to or hey do you want
help cleaning that mess up or something
I think those are inherently part of
good sex education but they're not
explicitly like about sex I think
growing up I didn't have much social
media so like I never like saw this
stuff but I go on Instagram now every
like just so many posts so many stories
are just about all these things about
sex consent and it can really go both
ways right there's extremes on both
sides but the age that it starts at you
should really just encourage your kid to
like you should tell them the bare
minimum the biological standard right
there's two biological Sexes stuff
happens but really let them do their own
research and encourage them to research
both sides rather than just like mainly
questions are you saying whenever they
get social media whenever they first
hear about it and they have any
questions about it so I grew up with
religious and conservative parents but
they never made it clear that those two
parts of my identity were the only
things that were to rule my entire
lifestyle so what I mean by that is
growing up I would hear about politics
whenever I would ask them a question
about it they never made it clear what
their stance on it was because they
wanted me to explore both sides and I
asked them questions you know they
always tell me to explore the thing
first you know go on Google research go
to different sources and then we can
have a discussion once I've really been
truly informed if we're empowering them
to do their own research they can get
into the very wrong sides of doing that
research for instance most people I know
got their sex out from porn and if we're
talking about you know sex and consent I
don't think anyone in the Stream is
thinking that porn is a great example of
sex ed my son definitely I definitely
caught my son watching porn and he's 14
years old and it was a conversation and
I didn't shame him you know but but if
this is already happening what do I look
like coming at him and reprimanding him
in time this is a boundary oh we don't
do this in this house because you're
gonna go to all this energy is like no
this is already happening so if now I'm
just now finding out about it so now
there's a communication like and we
actually had a whole on conversation
about why this isn't real and why this
is not okay for you you're going to be
an adult the rest of your life honey be
a 14 year old right now and he's like
you're right Mom no don't worry about it
again you're probably still sneaking and
watching porn but you know what I'm
saying I'm not going to stop that I'm
going to be able to communicate with
them and do the best I can do that's all
we can do but that's good because you
you told him about the stuff before it
got worse so I have a son and a daughter
my son is almost seven my daughter's
four
so you know I don't like to keep that
like if one's showering the other's in
their room vice versa but one thing I
guess I stepped forward for was mostly
because we use the word penis we use the
word vagina I want them to know their
Anatomy I want them to know that this is
what you have this is your nobody
touches this nobody sees it other than
you or like if I'm giving you a shower
or helping you wipe your butt like
things like that you know I learned
about sex
from boys being gross in class I didn't
know how anything worked and that's kind
of because like you said you didn't have
a good relationship with your parents I
didn't have that I wasn't comfortable
asking my mom or my dad like what is
this they probably should have been the
ones to educate me first probably
wouldn't have became a teen parent but
yeah I only hung back because I I agree
and I disagree like for me it was very
it was very interesting I have Mom and
Dad uh my mother is a very uh very Latin
woman uh so it's kind of funny that she
was the one who I talked to about sex
more than my dad I don't think I've ever
said more than two words to my dad up
until this day about sex so for my
daughter I almost kind of want to mirror
that for obvious reasons I mean that
might just be a better conversation for
her mom to have with her I mean I'm
willing to have a conversation but I
also feel a little bit uncomfortable at
the same time maybe that has to do with
my past I don't know but uh yeah I think
the younger people here have it
so incredibly difficult and so
incredibly easy just because they have
everything available to them at the same
time where like me you like you over
there like we have to figure stuff out
from like you know blurry VHS tapes or
like slow slow internet downloads and
stuff like that so it's very like I
don't I'm not I'm not jealous of you
guys at all that's fair that's fair to
say that I might not feel comfortable
talking to my daughter about intercourse
right that's completely it was way
easier for me to talk to my son about
how are like look you're good at
basketball you know what I'm saying or
you're gonna go to Athletics and whatnot
like I know how women are going to be
when it comes to courting yeah I can
talk to her probably a lot easier
absolutely I said disagree because of
the word necessary I don't think that
it's necessary
um you know everyone's watched Animal
Planet nobody teaches the the lion cubs
how to have sex or what what to do I
think it's ingrained in all of us
um I think it's just something that is
the result of evolutionary biology my
dad was a very strong masculine figure
in my life and he was always there for
me but I never had the birds and the
bees talk I just I never had it I went
through puberty I felt all the things
that young boys feel going through
puberty I used my eyes and I looked
around the world
um I talked to my friends like Curious
Kids do and we figured it out and we
kind of knew what was going on
but something you said actually made me
think and almost reconsider if I made
the right choice
um and that was about pornography
because this is a very big issue and
it's very pervasive in our society today
the average age of first exposure to
pornography in this country is 11 and
some social scientists are saying that
it's getting younger every year to keep
people viewing to keep the dopamine hits
coming to these viewers these young
viewers it's escalating behaviors it's
rape it's incest it's aggression it is
these horribly violent behaviors that
they're learning for the first time you
know by by 18 years old it's over 90
percent of young boys have seen porn and
sixty percent for young women and that
is something that we have to recognize I
think it is good to have some some
discussions about this but I also think
that this ties back to why it's
important to have a two-parent home
because it's not just about telling your
kids what is Right kids are very visual
Learners and so when they see your
mother and father interacting with each
other in a loving nurturing way they
internalize that they see that and and
they in turn go out and they treat other
people like that whether that's their
girlfriend or boyfriend and so that's I
think one of the big values of having a
two-parent two sex home I think being
honest because even being conservative I
think we can be a little hypocritical
like we're so perfect and we have this
perfect family but it's like no your
mama was a hoe you know you know your
dad used to do your dad used to sniff
Coke you know so we're not perfect and
just being honest and transparent and
seeing you know certain things in our
children and being able to address those
things in a timely manner so I don't
think that it's necessary for for my
kids age to talk about sex and I would
rather them just for now see the
intimacy between a mother and a father
before I drop that ball you know on them
so
children should strive to meet their
parents expectations
[Music]
apparently that's a valid question what
are those expectations do we do we do we
expect our kids to be rocket scientists
as soon as they're born probably not if
it's like good upstanding citizens who
love and respect their family and their
friends I think so and I'm sure there
are some children of immigrants here who
probably have a very high standard
expected of them from the day that they
were born or the day that they moved to
this country and that's one thing I wish
Asian American households like changed
we should always be expecting
Improvement I think that's the one thing
that parents should always be putting on
their kids thing is I was I was really
mad at math like I like did not learn
how to add positive negative numbers
until like seventh late eighth grade
which is really really bad okay
especially for an Asian
um but the thing is it doesn't matter
where your kid starts you should always
be encouraging them to improve you don't
set quantitative standards for them
saying get an A on this skip Beyond this
when you should be encouraging is oh you
gotta see try to get C plus b small
steps are what gets your kid there I
don't want to create uh not create but
raise a child that is reckless like okay
well you have the freedom be yourself
Express Yourself do whatever you want
and then you know she comes home you
know 16 and Pregnant I'm like you did
this and blah blah blah well Dad you
didn't tell me anything so the
expectations isn't to be perfect but
just take a little bit of the things
that she's learned you know that they've
learned from their mom and dad and
utilize them in their life to the best
of their abilities and if they can do
that I'm happy with it my parents in
style I feel is I would say strict but
it's not strict you know although my
children aren't allowed to be exposed to
certain things they still have an
amazing way of life because they get to
do things with their mother and father
who are actually present while they're
in their presence instead of scrolling
on social media and um ignoring the
child you know when the child could be
needing you more than you think so I
pride myself on being as present as I
can and setting that strong foundation
for my children I think it's also
important to teach your kids that the
expectations you're setting for them and
those goals that you're setting for them
isn't for you it's for them and that's
something really important that my
parents taught me was that here are the
goals here's what we expect out of you
but at the end of the day your successes
are your own and your failures are your
own and one day Mom and Dad aren't going
to be here and you're going to have only
yourself to look to for your
accomplishments and so it's setting the
goals and setting the bar but then
making them realize this is all you the
ball's in your court and your life is in
your hands it's not in ours the
expectation that I have is just they're
the best person that they could that
they could be and I think that's the
same for every parent I mean that's the
the goal and the wish that your child is
happy and healthy and content of who
they are and what they're doing and of
course I'm going to push them uh to take
the next step and I'll always push them
but you know I think that expectation is
is a valid one
I agree with a lot of this guys were
saying the reason I didn't fully step
forward was I immediately thought of my
parents and my parents both grew up in
conservative homes and we're told that
they should the the whole goal was to go
to college get a wife and have kids if
the expectation if my parents met the
expectation that they were going to have
a get married and have a wife and have
kids one they might have killed
themselves and not been here today two I
definitely wouldn't have been here my
brother wouldn't have been here so it
can't be the end I'll be all to meet
your parents expectations
my parents are immigrants from India and
their expectation for me is to
accomplish the American dream to blend
into white Society to blend into like
Rich American society they placed me
from the age of five in a all boys
school
um until the age of 15 and their
expectation was for me to blend in
I'm sorry I can't meet that like I'm a
woman I'm not going to meet your
expectation of going to an old boy
school that I don't think that's me
doing something wrong there that's me
just living my truth but there's other
exploitations that I think are very
appropriate for them to have me meet you
know they want me to go to a good
college they want me to succeed and be
happy and accomplish my dreams and I
think those are all wonderful but I
think it's not so black and white
foreign
elementary schools should teach students
about sexual orientation and gender
identity
I don't think they should teach like
queer Theory or like college level
gender classes but I think they should
be taught that
these kinds of people exist in the world
and you will grow up in a world with
where you need to love and respect these
people yeah for me that like if if we're
talking specifically elementary school
for me that just looks like having a
book in the classroom that is about a
two-dad family or is about someone
discovering that they like to wear
dresses and then maybe that that
disagrees with what they were born as
you know just something like a
children's book or just some kind of
picture on the wall that represents that
it doesn't have to be anything beyond
that that's not age appropriate you know
this doesn't involve gay sex education
or hormone therapy or like if we're
talking like elementary school kids it's
just it's just representation like just
putting it on everyone's radar those
people are out there at its core it's
not about you have to agree with this
and this is an agenda it's about you can
agree with this you can disagree with
this but you need to respect it you know
growing up I didn't have those books I
was questioning myself if I'm
normal quote or if I'm you know if
there's something wrong with me uh why
do I have these feelings is this correct
because I never had a conversation with
my parents my parents are straight my
whole family is very conservative so it
was really difficult for me to accept
myself because I didn't see the
acceptance anywhere else
it's the exact same thing as different
cultures different religions it's just
another diverse area that you need to be
exposed to it's like me being okay with
schools being taught uh heterosexual
relationships like I'm okay with that
that's something part of the world of
course like I didn't get any education
from it from school and you know kids
use like that's gays like you're gay
like as a derogatory you know so for me
it could be as simple as like this girl
has two dads my kids have two moms
simple
hmm
is it Brittany okay so you made a
statement just now that where you said
you do you think it should just be like
this exists and this exists and not go
any further so I think my problem with
the school system teaching our children
these things is that it doesn't just
stop there
and also what if your boundary is
different from her boundary from his
boundary from everybody's boundaries a
little bit different right as parents so
I don't think the schools understand
that and I don't think government
schools really should be raising our
children which they are now right you
know we should be really really raising
our own children and if we have to put
our children in a public school
hopefully they're learning reading
writing and arithmetic and the social
things and the cultural things and the
religious things that were that are
valuable to each one of us should come
from inside our household my Approach
with parenting is to be very loving very
tender a very good role model some
people would say I do some attachment
parenting because we still sleep in the
same bed but really it's um it's for a
number of reasons and one being safety
and two being it's more fun than being
across the house from my daughter when
we're the only two people in the house
we just have a very tender loving
relationship I wanted to make sure that
I cultivated that in my my relationship
with my child because I felt like I grew
up without that tenderness and that love
and that security in my my household so
I wanted to make sure that I provided
that for my daughter no matter what
you said I'm so sorry to keep bringing
this up I don't want to like trauma Bond
or anything but like you didn't have a
good relationship with your parents you
weren't able to go and talk to them
about sex or your period or things like
that correct
where was the best place to get that
information other than
school sex ed for you that's a great
point and I'm glad you brought that up I
wish that my parents
were open and communicative I had a
similar situation to you and so I ended
up learning it from my friends so
friends and magazines and VHS tapes
somebody mentioned like you learn about
these things other ways but still it
should come from the family I should it
doesn't always should come from the
family you because I can almost
guarantee that every single person here
and anybody who's a parent or just has a
parent we all have a different idea of
what we want our children to learn and
not learn about these particular social
constructs and sex and we exists
so I agree with a lot of what you guys
were saying when you guys are up here
about representation we should be
teaching our kids that people of
different sexualities you know family
types they exist but when you have one
entity one curriculum one school one
government when you have only one entity
teaching a thing that can go both ways
in a lot of different directions there's
a lot of room for bias like I I want my
my kids when I grow up I want them to
know that these different things exist
but in school it's just so hard to
regulate what's going on and I see news
stories all the time about these
children's books there's one book about
teaching I don't know their name but
it's about a girl exploring her
sexuality and in the book it literally
says her friend said maybe you should
try tasting your vaginal discharge to
see if you like it or not and the thing
is nobody's advocating for this stuff at
least I hope not but the DC it just I
can get so I can get out of hand so
quickly so it's understandable when it's
hard to regulate but again in schools it
is curriculum so it wouldn't be anything
outside of but it was being taught in
the curriculum like the students
I think some teachers be wilding out and
bringing in their own their own personal
stuff
absolutely not that sounds we forget
that you know we talk about you know the
school system and all that stuff but we
forget that these teachers are people
too you know um one of these teachers
are my age age you know they're young
exactly like so my daughter when she
went into kindergarten her teacher was
amazing great she loved my daughter
treated her very very well but the first
time I went to back I think it was back
to school and I had a parent-teacher
conference there was literally the whole
classroom was surrounded with rainbows
and I'm like rainbow pencils rainbow
ABCs rainbow rainbow right I'm like okay
we need to know our colors they need to
know our their colors that's cool but it
turned it went it went from like okay
you're teaching them to okay what is
this like you know I don't care if you
are gay or whatever you
no no no she you know she was married
had kids I don't know if her kids were
anything like that but it just was like
what are you trying to do it just felt
weird I think
no but no no no absolutely not that but
I mean for a 50 year old woman to have a
thousand rainbows in the classroom when
I grew up and there was maybe one or two
or three what's what what's the the fact
that it was thought that because there
was rainbows in the classroom that that
was pushing agenda to these kids is just
ludicrous to me I mean to think that a
queer person whether they're a parent or
not has a particular agenda to push
lgbtq community on other people is just
ridiculous and it really it triggered
something in me and I I bit my tongue
during that time when I was in fifth
grade I had a gay teacher we all knew he
was gay we all loved him and I also had
a classmate with with two moms and the
teacher recognized and said this this
student has two moms that's perfectly
fine we're not going to go any further
than that recognizing and seeing the
student and telling them that they're
safe here the problem today is what you
were talking about is that it's not just
recognition it's almost indoctrination
it's it's taking it past just showing
people that yes you exist and I
recognize you
I took uh sex ed from fifth grade too
and it was very simple it was the boys
went in one classroom with the male
teachers and the girls went into another
classroom with the female teachers and
we talked about the anatomy we could ask
questions about sex and questions about
puberty and other than that that was
kind of it but now across this country
you're seeing these types of books that
aren't just talking about the biology
and the anatomy and teaching kids about
procreation it's talking about pleasure
it's it's pornographic material and that
has no place in the classroom and
unfortunately we're almost having to
step back and have no sex education
which you want which we want which we
want sensible sex education because
people are taking it so far and and my
question my question to those people
that that agreed is why do you not think
that parents can sufficiently and
appropriately determine how and when
they talk to their kids about sex and
why are these teachers so eager to talk
to other parents children about sex and
gender ideology I've literally traveled
the country reporting on this
indoctrination on the the drag queen
Story Hour on the transition closets on
the coming out day and whether or not
you agree with those that's fine if you
agree with them but you have to also
agree that your child is in a classroom
with parents that feel very strongly
about those issues and that has to be
left to the parent it is not the
teacher's job to say today's coming out
day or to say that you can be called by
this pronoun or this pronoun or you can
go in either classroom to talk about
this Anatomy or this Anatomy it's just
not your job when it comes to pronouns I
feel like that teacher is creating a
safe space for that child in case they
do come home and they cannot come out
it's creating safe spaces for the
children that aren't like like I didn't
mean to point you guys out but you both
are very religious right and I
personally come from a very religious
household
no offense but I am uncomfortable as
hell you know being around Christians
not necessarily Christians but people
attacks we can be pretty tough no I
don't mean to like make you guys feel
uncomfortable because it's it's a
two-sided coin absolutely you know it's
like it was a convenience to be
Christian it's I'm going to become I'm
going to be Christian about the old
Covenant and not know what Christianity
really means on the New Covenant and I
know Christianity because I was went to
a ministerial school for three years so
you wanna talk about the Bible we can
talk about it but LGBT is not even
talked about in the New Covenant when
Jesus Christ came and washed away my
sins and I'm a Christian pause because
we do have to move on I want to hear
from Mike oh well no I was just gonna
say that that you know my wife and I
plan to homeschool for a multitude of
reasons specifically we don't want the
state involved in our child's education
there are a bunch of subjects we don't
even think should be taught to begin
with like earth science what the hell is
that all about
um but to point to Aldo's point one of
the reasons why especially recently why
we why we decided this was because we
went to our local school districts
library and those books absolutely exist
and we were told by the librarian that
an 8 to 12 year old can take those books
out without their parents permission and
these books they're kind of like comic
bookie types some of them are but some
of them have extremely pornographic uh
descriptions some of them have visual
aids some of them talking about hey try
a see how it makes you feel
someone talks about fingering yourself
I'm absolutely not open to having my
daughter look at that stuff let alone
even hear about it from other kids and
second of all with the teachers in the
classrooms I feel like there is a larger
subset of teachers who seem to have an
agenda this is just what I see optically
and it's just not something that I'm
comfortable with so I quickly ask raw a
question
you talked about creating a safe space
for students with pronouns
do you recognize that some parents that
feel very strongly about these issues
that by these teachers creating these
safe spaces for students and introducing
all the students to the the spectrum of
gender ideology creates a dangerous
space for that that other child that
it's introducing them to an idea that
the parents feel strongly about do I
think creating a safe space for queer
and trans kids creates an unsafe place
for straight kids absolutely not that
the parents though that you recognize
that the parents could feel that way but
the introduction of these ideas is not
aligning with their values and it's not
okay I agree a thousand percent with
homeschooling I worked at LAUSD for 10
years and I've seen a lot of that
goes on in the school district I
absolutely believe that it starts at
home if you give your kids a good
foundation at home they should be able
to have a little bit of a foundation
when they go to schools and recognize
you different things like oh I don't
agree with that I don't get jiggy with
that but I'm not going to hate and
disrespect the person that does so
because there are kids that are
committing suicide there are kids that
are coming to school that that come to
school for safety for food not only just
to learn about sex Ed but literally
because I have no other place to go but
to go to school for food in the morning
what about the kid though who's made to
feel out to be like a pariah let's say
if there's one kid who's like well you
know that's maybe not what I believe
with the pronouns or with any sort of I
don't care about pronouns right exactly
sure so now today I feel like there are
kids who are probably going to be Pariah
by their teacher maybe if they're you
know if he or she's a bad teacher I
don't know that's not necessarily
inclusive or maybe a safe space for that
one child who you know may feel like I
don't believe in any of this stuff it's
not just about making the kids in the
school feel safe it's about educating
the people that don't know how to treat
other people outside of the school so
they can take that with them and respect
people that are not inside the school
sometimes a child needs a spanking
this is interesting because let me get
close I feel that every kid needs a
spanking though my wife and I have
decided that we're not going to spank
our kid
if that makes any sense like it does I
grew up being spanked and I turned out
all right for it but
I do think that spanking can be or you
know physical what's the word physical
discipline or physical correction uh can
be useful but uh yeah not for mine the
thing is like you can take this question
both ways there are cases where you
should not spank a child but I think
about behaviors that are have been
ingrained that have been enabled for a
long time that are terrible and they
should stop I used to work at a tech
summer camp and there's this little girl
who's the demon she would like go up to
the Indian kids say you're ugly you're
bound you smoke like these are things
that are enabled a kid isn't born and
has this hate towards Indian people you
know what I mean so I think a case like
that and when the mom came she was just
like honey you can't continue doing that
it's been enabled so I think there are
cases where the only way to get to the
kid's Head is by showing like extreme
like concern and like for some parents
you know that can come through spanking
but I don't think it should be used for
like mild cases like you got to be on a
test or something like that right so and
what do we do we mirror our parents
Behavior so because I grew up with you
know my mom's bank me and my dad rarely
did but if you ever like if he ever got
to the point of a spanking it happened
but I think that my first inclination
when my daughter would have a tantrum
would just almost kind of be like to
either grab it really hard or to just
think about you know this kid needs a
spanking and I used to tell my wife I
used to be like just just let me do it
let me see what happens but it just kind
of restrained ourselves and we just said
you know we decided at first and it may
seem like a very like unconservative
thing to say but like yeah we came to
the decision we're not going to do that
so for me
um you know being African-American I
feel like our forms of discipline are
more
um brutal in some senses uh because
they're not really given with love you
know uh you know I remember getting
whoopings just for laughing too early in
the morning on a Saturday watching
cartoons you know so because they're
trying to sleep so I think that like
when I spank my daughter I always make
sure she understands why she's getting
the spanking so it's not you know she
touched something and then I you know
get her it's hey you know you shouldn't
climb that because you can Farm really
hurt yourself and then I leave the room
and come back in and she's doing it it's
like okay you know so uh the term that
I've always used with her when I've
given her spankings is do you need
understanding and she's like Daddy I
don't want understanding like I don't
want any understanding but after I've
spanked her I'll give her a minute and
then I'll come back in the room and say
all right let's have a conversation and
sit down like why did I spank you
because Daddy I was climbing the ladder
what could have happened I could have
really fallen and hurt myself so what do
we not do climb the ladder if you're not
there it's done right this goes back to
the conversation we were having about
expectations and trying to meet those
expectations and as a parent if you set
an expectation for your child that has
to do with their safety and it's not met
and you don't correct them then that's
actually not loving then that's actually
not showing your child that there are
consequences to the actions and that'll
lead them to doing the same behavior
over and over again and also say that
it's if you are constantly having to
spank and use this extreme measure then
you're probably doing something else
wrong that needs to be corrected first
so it does have to be used sparingly and
not that extreme um you're exactly right
I grew up in a Latin household in Puerto
Rican and we got the switch we got the
belt we got the hand we got the fist we
got all of it you get the backhand the
backhand We Got The Wooden Spoon we got
all of it and
it was terrifying at times honestly and
sometimes I didn't feel it was justified
sometimes it was justified but I didn't
want to create an environment for my
child where it was severe punishment
that felt like they were so terrified of
me that they weren't going to be able to
be somewhat free right the punishment
needs to fit the crime if you look at
the animal kingdom I'll talk about that
again but they physically correct their
young ones when there's danger when
they're when they're out of line and
they teach them because
verbalizing doesn't always work and I
think it should just be minor
corrections I don't think we should get
into the realm of abuse obviously and
also I feel like these days you can't
even touch your child without you know
somebody wanting to call CPS on you when
I was growing up there was no laws you
could just beat the tarnation out of
your child apparently but um but now you
know you have to be very careful legally
but from a biological standpoint I think
it should just be very slight and the
punishment should fit the crime
the first thing that bugs me about this
conversation that it always seems to be
oh yeah I got those smacking and always
ends up being a laughter that follows
what stories of people getting spanked
um I respect uh I had my mouth washed
out with soap uh I had my pants
literally pulled down around my ankles
and spanked in front of my in front of
my friends
as a child first of all that
embarrassment
it was hard to come back from very very
hard not only that but my relationship
with my father completely suffered
because of it I presented him I hated
him
I feared him and it was a long like I'm
still trying to repair it from this day
and I think that as a parent now that
I'm in that position and my child acts
up yet of course we we have to
discipline them but sending them to time
out which they hate and despise and then
having that conversation of why did you
go to timeout and they understand and
they repeat what they're not supposed to
do you know it works and they don't do
it again and I think we can get the
point across and discipline our children
without abuse without hitting without
spanking because that is a lasting
impression on a child I think with the
Lasting Impression right the physical
pain is temporary the mental pain is
lifelong forever and I don't think that
a child and now adults should have to
live with that trauma for the rest of
our lives just because our parents
wanted to correct Us in that one moment
honestly I don't think spankings are
really effective
um you know spare the rats boil the
child I come from parents that we had a
huge leather belt and I would not I
think about it we'd always get total I
don't maybe get the leather belt and dad
did get the leather belt but I never got
hit with that belt and it was more to
put invoke that fear because I could
never imagine my parents honestly
hitting me and I didn't have to get hit
to mind or to respect them but the
moment that my parents were to hit me I
would lose respect for them because I
wouldn't expect I don't expect my
parents to have to hit me I don't think
that's what parents should have to do if
you can't use your words to articulate
to your children to respect you we have
a bigger problem yeah first time I ever
did get physically spanked was by my
grandpa's wife I lived with her and blah
blah blah and she's she smacked me and I
smacked her back you know like I wasn't
gonna take that I don't take that kind
of disrespect
and like I don't touch my kids like that
I don't feel like my little
four-year-old daughter
why does she need to be spanked she's
four my six-year-old he's still learning
the world around him he doesn't need
that that's abusive to me no offense but
like I just see it as abuse
thinking absolutely was something I
couldn't imagine even speaking of on
camera for millions of people to see and
I don't see the
point of abuse in children as little as
six four you know that's very young and
very imprinting on children that you
know are going to grow up and think that
that's how you discipline and that's how
you get people to hear what you're
saying it leaves mental scores when it's
used in the wrong scenario so we were
talking about that earlier if you're
speaking your kid every single day
there's there's a taste your parenting
but you only use it when it's a terrible
behavior that needs to stop like when I
was little okay I used to shoplift okay
I would get away with it I thought you
could just take a candy bar and then
leave but after like my parents found
these like chocolate bars that they
weren't paying for they spanked me and
as they should because if they hadn't
spanked me they just said honey don't do
this I would have kept on if they just
said don't do that you might have
just stopped or took something away from
you or use a different effective ways
the thing is taking things away from my
son like me smacking my son my son's 14
years old who's bigger than me stronger
than me me emasculizing my son and
smacking him as a woman and telling him
he's doing something wrong that's wild
that's not going to be effective at all
it's no hey let's talk about this you're
gonna get Xbox taken away you know I'm
not going to take this AAU practice that
we're spending spending 400 we're going
to do something that's going to be
really effective that you actually are
going to remember because hitting after
a while that don't mean nothing all
right keep on hitting me keep on hitting
me
I agree with that being you know uh
you know what I mean so you know when
you're 12. you know my mom was like your
height you know so I think to kind of go
off what you were saying the laughter
part we're not laughing because of the
spanking it's more so and I hope this
makes sense
it's laughing because of the experience
of love in the discipline that I
experienced with my daughter and the
fact that she now understands and I know
that she won't make that same mistake
again now to what you were saying
um after spanking her I I don't remember
the last time I've spanked my daughter
because now even with my two-year-old
when they're acting up or doing
something or Screaming or going crazy
and I'm like hey guys stop and they're
still going I'll get the belt and I'll
just jingle okay Dad we're sitting down
and I'm like oh so you you guys are good
yeah Dad we're good it's like I don't
have to as a response absolutely like oh
we don't want to get hit we don't
want to go ahead but also it's a
respecting like that's my father he's in
there you know trying to work on the
computer or something we are screaming
too loud it's the job of the parent to
make sure the child can come to them for
anything and everything and overall love
why would you teach a child that that
person would hit them that's it
the sexuality of parents influences
their kids sexuality
now if we're talking about sexuality as
in just you know being openly openly
like uh
I hope I'm wearing this the right way
promiscuous or your behaviors
um I think it does
um a lot of things that I do my kids do
a lot of things that my wife do you know
they follow her so I think if
um I was behaving in a certain way and
um you know behaving treating my wife a
certain way in front of my daughters and
my son you know I think it would affect
the way that they treat themselves and
the way they they treat others and um
would look at sex as more as an object
or just something to do more than a
intimate
um thing that you have with one person
that you know creates a real Bond and a
friendship
the thing about childhood is that every
kid has a normal one because there's no
frame of reference Everything's Relative
so whatever you put into that child's
life becomes their normal children that
are from same same-sex households they
have a higher chance of identifying as
lgbtq and you could claim that this is
because they're more accepting and more
receptive to that but I would say that I
would point to the the generations that
each generation as as they got older the
amount of people the percentage of
people that identify as lgbtq doubles
each generation and some of that can be
because of acceptance of society but I I
do not believe that it is pure
acceptance there is influence that's
happening on our social media uh that's
happening in Media or in the world but
it starts at home and they're definitely
there is influence in the home that when
you see this as normal it will of course
influence your sexuality and how you
view these things I just want to say
quickly that the sexuality in the home
should be a good role model for your
children should be construct it should
be loving and not toxic if a child sees
sexuality and sees it as toxic they may
just choose to go the other way
a lot of gay people have straight
parents a lot of gay parents produce
straight kids so debunked you you cannot
if you're straight that doesn't mean
your child is straight if you're gay
that doesn't mean your child is gay I
want to stand firm on the fact that
sexuality is biological it's not
something you can choose and if it's
something you want to explore that's
different from choosing
exploring is oh maybe I'll go see what
it's like being with a woman oh that
didn't feel right
because it's biological yeah so two
points one of which is something that
you had said about them only knowing the
gay that there's two gay parents and so
they relate to that more in my life like
yes there is two gay parents but we also
are surrounded by a lot of straight
parents and a lot of straight couples
and their friends come over to play and
they have a mom and dad and they come
over so them being only
seeing this one thing and then thinking
oh maybe I'm gay because that's the only
thing I know I don't believe in that I
don't think that I just think what is
normal to them is it normal to for them
to have two dads of course right having
a mom and a dad is it normal but it's
also normal to see other kids with their
mom and dad too I mean they see it all
the time and then my second other was uh
just the fact of a choice I mean you
talked about it it's definitely not a
choice if I had to choose way back when
I was 15 14 thinking oh gosh I'm gay I
would not choose to have Society
constantly looking at me judging me when
I'm out to dinner with my two girls and
people come up and go you're doing such
a good job you don't do that to straight
parents who are out with their kids like
why come up to me so I would not have
chosen to be gay if I had the choice
I am gay I am happy my life is amazing
and I wouldn't want it any other way but
back then when I was figuring things out
I wouldn't have chosen it I said they do
they do Straight parents especially
being a black father I get it all day
long on the other side of things I want
to talk about this notion of what is
normal influences what you are I went to
an all-boy school I'll say this a
million times I went to an all-boy
school until I was 15. I did not know
where the girl was until I was 15. my
parents are heterosexual they're pretty
conservative they are Christian nothing
in my environment was saying you need to
be a girl you are queer you like are
lesbian right
that was just always within me and
nothing in my environment pushed me to
do that
um I think that is just one very clear
example that your environment does not
make you have a particular sexuality or
gender that is just within you
the way I was parented made me feel safe
and seen
my parents already knew that they were
getting into parenting
um miles behind other people because the
world tells them they're going to be
this kind of parent simply because
they're gay from what they've told me
before I was born before my brother was
born it was doing all kinds of research
on what works for kids how to raise a
girl what girl puberty is like all of
these things they made sure that they
were super educated so that the only
reason the world could tell them they
were a bad parent is because they were
gay and that means nothing that comes
down to your own opinion and so I grew
up feeling so safe so supported I came
to my parents with any question and they
always had the answer
um and I always knew I could grow up
being whatever I wanted to be uh and
whether that was sexuality whether that
was career-wise
um I honestly growing up with two dads
was really beneficial as a woman because
there was nothing impeding on or there
were no boundaries set on what a woman
should be or what a woman should act
like it was no you go out and your brain
is your biggest asset and it's the most
beautiful thing about you go out and do
whatever you want women can do whatever
men can do and it was really great
actually to not have a woman in the
household that maybe would have
um derailed that
in some way I half agree I would say I
felt safe I did not particularly feel
seen
my parents don't know it being trans is
they don't really understand what being
gay was when I came out to them they
were like we don't really know what this
is but we love you and that's what made
me feel safe even if they don't
particularly see me they came to see me
and at the end of the day if they say I
love you and you're welcome here that's
what matters so for me to be met with
love from conservative values was pretty
shocking because
I just have so much experience of
observing media where Christians are
always paired with
anti-lgbt rhetoric and conservatism is
not compatible with this but in my own
personal life I've seen the two be
completely compatible you can be
conservative and you can be queer you
can be Christian and you can support
LGBT people and that's something I
didn't really think was possible but my
parents proved me wrong in that way
I feel like I grew up with the best
parents in the world they did everything
that they could to make me the best
person I am today and there were a lot
of times growing up that we were going
through really difficult times but they
shielded us from that there were times
that we the low lights turned off or the
heat turned off and as kids we don't
know what's going on we just ask hey
what's what's going on oh you know your
mom forgot to pay the bill and all these
things were hidden from us until we were
way older and we look back at those
things and we realized now they that she
didn't forget to pay the bill or we left
the tags on not because they wanted us
to choose a different shirt later on
it was because there was serious stuff
going on in my family but they shielded
us from that so that we could be kids
and my father you know he took me out
hunting took me to my sports taught me
what it was like or and how to be a man
how to be a good man how to treat women
um and conversely my mom taught me how
to nurture women and the things that a
mother teaches a young son and I feel
like I had the best parents the best
experience and
I can't think of something better can't
think of anything better my dad's
probably one of the most soft-spoken
individuals I've ever met my entire life
but I remember instances of feeling safe
because I would see him literally snap
to Dad protection mode when it came to
you know anyone trying to harm us or my
mother anything like that and as far as
being seen my parents stayed like all of
our parents they had the expectations we
talked about about us being successful
in our career but I had so many wants
and desires from being a teenager like
wanting to be oh I want to be a magician
I want to be a skateboarder who was by
me magician kids who was buying me
skateboards like I had the most
supportive and I guess you can use the
word seeing parents that you could ever
ask for and you know I I owe them
everything that I am today the person
that I am today is because of them
my parents didn't agree with my
lifestyle I came out super super early I
came out like around 12.
um and my next my parents are pastors
but my mom always saw me and when I
asked to dress like a boy in like fifth
grade my dad was super resistant because
he kind of knew but you know when your
kids are gay early on you just know and
I think inherently they knew I was going
to be gay and my dad was not getting
jiggy with it and my mom was like let
her be her let her be her she'll figure
it out and I lost my dad about three
months ago parents were married 50 years
same household the best people were I'll
give you a run for your money because my
parents were pretty great too
um in this last birthday my parents sent
me a card it was the first time they've
ever said anything like this to me which
they we accept you we unapologetically
accept you and we love you and that
meant more to me than anything in the
world I'm 36 years old and finally my
mom and dad and I needed that and then
for people that are hearing this yeah
your kids no matter how old they get
they need to hear their parents accept
them and validate them it's important it
does make you feel good so yeah my
parents are pretty awesome
I want to start by saying my dad is not
the problem my dad is super supportive
you know he was invited to my wedding he
walked me down my aisle you know
and my mom wasn't invited my mom didn't
come to my wedding my mom didn't get to
do you know the normal Bridal stuff
because she did not agree with
My Lifestyle but this is
by far the happiest that I've ever been
the most headstrong that I have been
and if she can't support that then I
don't want her in my life and
a lot of my family and friends have been
kind of like finally you finally cut her
out
and
so you know
it hurts sometimes but like also I'm
protecting my kids from that exposure
that hatred that acceptance that that
she doesn't have for me my kids don't
need that it's 2022 these kids my kids
are the Next Generation
I want them to know nothing but
acceptance loving caring people that's
it
growing up you know I think it was kind
of the same way you know they didn't
tell me a lot in order to protect what I
would think about situations
um
and my my dad and I you know I've kind
of talked about that a little bit but
you know we didn't have a good
relationship just because you know we
did not connect on any kind of level but
my mom and I really really connected and
I felt safe with her uh up until I came
out to her and it was
it was such a
bummer moment because we had such a
strong relationship and I felt her just
pull away from me when that happened and
it hurt me and we we didn't talk for a
little while and she said she supported
me but her words were not matching with
her actions and especially the past
couple years with what's been going on
in the world and politics and all of
that it seems like we're even getting
further and further apart and it's it
breaks my heart and it's sad and you
know I want to go back to when I was 10
and rekindle that relationship and now
that I have a family and kids and all my
family is just so important to me that
if she doesn't want to be on board and
if she doesn't believe in the beliefs
that I have you know like I'm I'm not
gonna go out of my way to try to
convince you if you're already set in
your ways and
it's sad but it's something that that
has to happen
yeah
Brittany I see you I see you girl
um yeah like I said before I didn't have
a relationship a safe relationship with
my mom or my dad
um so I I did seek some good modeling I
saw some good modeling with my friends
um and their families and actually the
first time I ever saw somebody say I
love you was at a friend's house in like
sixth or seventh grade and I saw her mom
say I love you
and I thought what
they say I love you and then she would
sit on her mom's lap and they would hold
hands and I thought oh my God weird huh
what are they doing I thought it was so
bizarre okay I have the opposite
relationship with my daughter we're very
loving very open very tender
um but honestly you know and and the
relationship I I told you it was mended
with my with my parents but honestly
they're still broken everybody's still
broken we're all broken
what mended me the most was I'll say it
again is having the relationship with my
true father that's what mended me the
most out of anything that's ever
happened and I've gone to therapy I've
gone to psychics I've gone to everybody
and I've done everything you can
possibly think of to heal from the
traumas and nothing nothing healed me
like the relationship with Jesus that I
have and that love and that security and
that tenderness is
that's in that safe space that's the
most safe you'll ever feel because
nothing that anybody else on the planet
says can matter to you when you know who
you are from the Creator 100 anybody can
throw a stick and a stone at me none of
it matters when you know who you belong
to and so that's what I have conveyed
now to my child that no matter what is
on the outside no matter how much pain
each of our families brings to us or our
external circumstances bring to us none
of it's going to shake us because we
know who we are it's kind of hard
because I don't know what it's like to
be a single black mother you know and
the the struggles that come from it you
know my dad I have a good relationship
with him uh the blessing that I've I
have of not being seen and not feeling
loved is that I got to watch
so being alone you know the only child
being alone I got to see certain
behaviors and you know I have relatives
that do drugs I'm 33 I've never smoked a
drink a day in my life you know I've
never done you know a lot of things and
it's because God put a hedge around me
and a protection around me to be able to
watch I understood at a very young age
what love was because I wasn't getting
love so I knew when I had my children I
knew exactly what to do it is I
understand that you know there's mental
health there's trauma there's a lot of
things that are out there that people
you know suffer with
how do you not know how to love your
child
it's especially as a black man being a
father
um real quick uh one time me and my
daughter we were at a restaurant and I
was getting her some food and this guy
this black guy sitting at the table and
he's like watching me and my daughter
and I'm like you know protection mode
like why are you staring at my daughter
and she's wearing this dress you know
I'm just like freaking out right so I
pay for the food turn around he's behind
me and he's like I just want to tell you
thank you and I'm like what's up he's
like dude I've been sitting here for
three hours waiting for my baby mom to
bring my daughter here I haven't seen
her in months and he was like and didn't
he like a tear came down he's like I
finally got to see what I want so you
know to not have that my mom she did the
best she could I love my mother I
haven't spoke to my mom in three years
my wife hasn't spoke to her family in
six and it's because of the protection
and the love that we have in our home
that it's like hey you're not gonna come
to my house and talk about my daughter
because she has mixed hair and you want
me to put a perm in her hair because you
don't like how curly it is no you can I
don't care if I never see you again it's
about my family so the cutting off I'm
100 with you but the not being seen and
not having that love
um the providing was there but just not
having that love I feel like I I took it
in as kind of a blessing because now I
get to love my kids
like like
[Music]